I'm Lauren Hodge.
I live in York, Pennsylvania and I'm 14 years old.
York is a great place to live.
There's a lot of nature and things to do outdoors.
And a lot of exploring.
Maybe that's why I started exploring the world around me.
I play the piano and violin.
Music allows me to challenge myself creatively, and it also inspires my work.
I love problem-solving.
I love asking questions and then working to find the answers,...
...and that's why science is so appealing to me.
It all starts with a question.
Last year, I was sitting in the doctor's office, leafing through a magazine,...
...and I came upon an article about the carcinogens in grilled chicken.
Later that night, my mom was actually grilling chicken, so it got me thinking.
It was like everyday life presented me with a problem, and now I needed to solve it.
So I started wondering about what caused the carcinogens...
...and if there's any way to deal with it.
I thought marinades might provide a practical solution,...
...so I devised a way to test different marinades on chicken...
...and see whether they reduced carcinogens.
After a lot of testing, I found that several marinades...
...did reduce the carcinogenic effects of grilling.
If you can decrease anything dangerous like carcinogens in something normal like chicken,...
...it can really help increase the quality of life for people...
...that aren't really aware of anything dangerous.
Being a winner in the 2011 Google Science Fair opened a lot of doors for me.
It all started with one question.
And I would encourage other kids out there to ask their own questions,...
...and then embark on their journey to find an answer.